my first Big Finish Doctor Who in which
the doctor makes no appearance Doctor
Who Big Finish time and this one
selected by my patrons over on patreon
go support me I'll plug it again at the
end there's a link in the description
I'll get on with Israel things so for
Big Finish this time I am taking a look
at the first entry in the miniseries i
Davros and so that the name of that one
is innocence now I Davros as I mentioned
is a miniseries now this is my first
encounter with Big Finish miniseries and
I hadn't realized how incomplete
listening to just one of these is so I
part of me feels like I man I should
have done the entire thing except I
didn't you know I didn't get the whole
thing I just got the first one I'm like
oh check this out maybe get the rest
later like if I had been smart and done
more research I just would have gotten
the whole idea for a set and done it all
in one go but a because I'm dumb so I am
just looking at this at this first piece
and like it's that first time with the
the miniseries as opposed to you know
the completely encased adventures which
is what I've been dealing with so far
when it comes to big fish now you should
tell from the title but just in case I
die for us does deal with the the
character of Davros ie the creator of
the Daleks so if you don't know diverses
backstory if you've never seen Genesis
of the Daleks which is where most of his
backstory is laid out he was a
physically enfeebled scientist of a race
called the khalid x' and they were on
their planet of Skaro they were at war
like a centuries-long war with another
race called the falls and they fought
basically to a stale
for a very long time like whatever once
I did the other side just basically took
an eye for an eye but neither ever
really gained an advantage and they were
starting to to get close to using
nuclear weapons and eventually you know
would start doing it and the nuclear
fallout resulting from that began some
mutations which is where Davros came in
Davros was a scrupulous in scrupulous
unscrupulous he has no scruples
scientist of the kal ads and he came to
the belief that whatever the radiation
was going to turn them into eventually
was inevitable so he went out of his way
to speed up that radiate the radioactive
induce mutation and then take the
resulting sickly malformed tentacled
mutant and put it in a tank slash
life-support and that is your Dalek
casing so that now that's all backstory
or actually forward store because this
as I just said before well before any of
that but that's that's all stuff that
was established before this mini series
was done as I said starting with Genesis
of the Daleks so back to the Fourth
Doctor
now what Ida Burris does is it takes a
look at his earlier life and sort of his
rise to his position where we we first
saw him in genesis of the Daleks
so for innocence this first one he is
fifteen so he is being raised his father
wants him to be a soldier his mother
wants him to be a scientist
his mother's a politician his father's a
soldier his mother wants him to be a
scientist because she believes that that
ultimately the scientists and what
weapons or counter actives they're able
to devise are what our
ultimately going to decide the fate of
this war and she wants him to be at the
forefront that verse is something of a
child prodigy he is super super smart
and as a result he's also kind of
condescending and a little bit full of
himself and he's also a bit cold and
that sort of gets brought out as the
story goes along so the choice to make
him 15 was probably a solid age to go
with because you go to much older than
that and he's more or less fully formed
and you feel like you still don't
understand why he is the way he is now
at 15 he's already pretty heavily
leaning towards we're you know becoming
at least in terms of approach and
mentality the character that we would
that you know fans already knew but he's
he's far enough back on his evolution to
that where you can see that there is
going to we are gonna see you know a
transformation over time and if you went
to much younger than 15 you pretend you
risk running into the young Anakin and
episode 1 of Star Wars issue which is
that you've gone so young and so
innocent that you you can't take it
seriously
um yes there are other reasons
Anakin die young doesn't work but having
him be that young and being like this
will be Darth Vader looking at that's
just a kid that's part of the problem
but in any case we get a mostly time
with his family in this we get time with
his mother his father his sister his
aunt and the other characters that we
get all still tie back into that we deal
with this tutor that his mother has set
him up with we deal with an officer that
is basically taking over for his father
because his father is sick and dying
from radiation and we get to see you or
hear you know how things begin to
progress for Davros and
we get a sense of how his philosophies
get formed and who some of the people
pushing him in the direction of what he
would ultimately become are and how was
they did that and whether or not they
meant to create the monster we
eventually know and it is interesting
it's pretty well done as far as these
sorts of things go I always think it's
hazardous to try and flesh out the
background of not even just villains
like of any character who basically
already arrived fully formed when they
were you know introduced in whatever
piece of media it tends to be so this
sort of thing can't can go very wrong
and I don't think it does here I think
this is pretty solid stuff and it works
and it just works it's it's interesting
as well play we have Terry Malloy
playing Davros he played Davros in the
classic era more than any other actor he
wasn't the first that was Michael wisher
and then I forget the second I forget
the name of the guy who did it in
destiny of the Daleks somebody will put
it in the comments somebody always does
when I forget something or get something
wrong but after that starting with
resurrection of the Daleks Terry Malloy
was the go-to Davros until classic who
ended so he's back in is actually pretty
damn convincing voicing a teenager I was
surprised he does that quite well and
because he knows this character so so
well he is infusing it with that sense
of we're of hinting at where he's gonna
go and have it read legitimate and have
it read well the supporting characters
are all pretty solid it's interesting
getting a little bit more of a look at
the at the war and the Khalid Society
and how things work there and how much
of a priority is put on military service
and basically everything is geared
towards how will this help us win the
war you know whether it is yeah you know
Davros wants to be a scientist but you
know he could be a politician he could
be a soldier but no matter what he is
whatever that is is going to be
he pushed it away and how does this help
with the war effort and yeah it's it's
good and it's interesting and and it
gives you that that background and it
feels very consistent none of none of
this feels like retcons this feels like
oh well that feels like what it always
would have been this isn't someone
trying to reinvent the wheel this is
somebody doing you know pretty much what
makes sense for this guy's backstory to
be but it just works well I think a good
comparison might be say the flashback
episode for kingpin for Fisk in the
first season of daredevil when he gets a
flashback episode to basically explain
why he is the way he is more or less
it's not any surprise it basically is
pretty much exactly what you'd think it
would be for a guy like him but it's
still well done and interesting to see
and that's kind of how I dubrow's plays
or at least this first bit of it does if
I were to register any complaints I
think the main one would just be and
this is a little bit of a small of a
spoiler I don't think it's too huge
though especially if it's your attention
to just go through the whole miniseries
and not be an idiot like me and just
listen to one part of a four part thing
without plans to listen to the other
three the the thing that that bothers me
is how heavily his mother seems to
factor into his just development going
down the path of where he's gonna end up
and there's just something about it if
it feels to me and and I didn't I I
should have looked some of this up to
see if it is as prevalent as it feels
but it does feel to me as though really
strong son - mother connections ie mommy
issues is quite often a bit of a cheat
and a shortcut and a just easy go to the
rule of thumb for these kinds of
twisted characters you know it's it's
you Norman Bates it's it's the version
of Oswald Cobblepot from Gotham at this
sort of thing just feels like it comes
up a lot with wood these kinds of
characters you know he had you know a
father who was not a great guy but you
know wanted the best Furman and then a
mother that fed his worst instincts and
yeah again I don't know if this is as
big of a trope as I'm thinking it is but
I feel like if there's a parent that
pushes a character towards being evil
whether they mean to do it or it's just
what ends up happening as a result of
their overprotectiveness excessive
meddling you know what have you it's
usually the mother like your fathers
shape kids for the old that's usually in
the form of being negligent or
physically or verbally abusive so yeah
it it just bugs me and it's not an
inherent problem it's not an inherent
fault with the story it functions fine
just yeah rubbed me the wrong way a
little bit with how much of an emphasis
that kind of got that really is though
my only complaint of substance I think I
can safely recommend this even though I
haven't listened to the other three
parts I am gonna recommend just getting
the whole miniseries if you can afford
to do it because it while innocence is
actually a decent listen on its own and
it it's not a complete story it does
have a fair ending point though it does
feel like we have completed this chapter
of this characters formal years and end
his life and it does and it's a natural
stopping point it's not like it ends on
a cliffhanger necessarily but it is very
much not a complete story it's part one
of four and feels like part one of four
it just thankfully does have you know
sort of a little mini more or less
completed segment
for its section but it's very it's very
obvious that it's a part of something
great
so I dab Russ innocence what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all that
stuff to do you know the stuff like
subscribe support me on patreon follow
me on Twitter bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla links for all that stuff is down in
the description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]